should someone always be detached okay
straightforward question the answer is
no someone shouldn't always be detached
because otherwise you aren't enjoying
anything in your life so don't always be
attached detached no but at the same
time that being said you should be aware
all the time if you are getting sucked
into the emotional vortex right you've
got to be aware of that once you have
that awareness you don't need to be
attached all the time at all
you can I'm not always detached at all
but but I've got clear warning signs
when things start going sideways and I
start going down some vortex I know
immediately I just detach so it's really
easy it's but it's a does take practice
and eventually you realize that you know
when you're feeling overwhelmed when
you're feeling emotional and you're
feeling angry or you're feeling
frustrated when you start feeling those
things and you've sent them really
quickly and you recognize them you just
detach boom you're done yeah so that's
what you got to do is start recognizing
those red flags so that you can enjoy
the good things and when something
starts getting crazy you can detach yes
so it's like an overall skill of being
able to control when to detach and when
you don't have to being able to identify
yeah when you need to detach yeah then
being able to detach then you're good
yeah so it's like it's a matter of being
capable of making an accurate beneficial
choice yes but the identification is the
hard part yes people what happens to
people when they talk to me is they go
they after the fact they realize I lost
my temper and I did this yeah okay you
didn't detach in time and that's why you
ended up there yeah so or I said some
things to my you know my ex-girlfriend
that I shouldn't have said because I got
too emotional exactly
you didn't detach in time yeah you got
crazy and emotional so the skill that
you're missing is identifying when
you're starting to get too emotional
whatever that emotion might be once you
identify boom detach yeah control then
you
take control yeah and make tactical
moves yeah
not emotional move that's ultimately the
art you know the move you know how like
jiu-jitsu guys if they never take no you
know what the moves when you're
emotionally detach the moves actually
aren't that hard they're actually
usually pretty obvious mmm
like you're you're in a fight with your
girlfriend and and you're starting to go
down the wrong lane as soon as you did
that you go oh I know what I need to do
yeah I should say I'm sorry and tell her
that we can go to the restaurant that
she wants to go to or whatever you know
I mean the moves are not actually that
hard we never make good moves when we're
being emotional instead we just go no I
don't want to go to that restaurant we
went there three weeks Turo
I don't care if I said that to you you
deserve me to say that to you yeah yeah
yeah you go down the wrong path but what
if somebody's like detached the whole
time even when problems don't arise you
know like that then we don't have a
relationship right that's what I mean
that's that's what I'm saying so not
being detached all all the time that's
what that's the answer the question
right so let's leave reiterated it for
everyone yeah Matthew hey I want to
learn you get to I want to learn to mess
people up bro that's not really what it
is
jujitsu is having the skills to quote
mess people up but what you learn
ultimately is you put yourself in a
position where you can make that
decision isn't I'm the mess I'm gonna or
not you know and controls you Jitsu so
that's really what most people that
start with the vision of I want to build
a mess people up most people continue
that that do continue on the journey of
jiu jitsu
arrive at a point where they realize
that they don't want to abuse this power
that they have yeah most people yeah
there is a small percentage of people
that don't that are bullies yeah
bullies when they started they become
more effective bullies yeah more fearful
more more fear in posing bullies yeah
which sucks yeah but you did to his
power that's where you gotta have some
of it yeah agree but compared to like a
I don't know anything where it's like
striking based or whatever it's like you
it like I've said this where I'm not
gonna go deep in it but you go from zero
to ten when you throw a strike Tanner
no you can't just throw a light one and
be like okay are we
no you just lapped me in the face
wrinkled oh you brought it to ten when
you knocked him out or not it was funny
because like I see I see my kids and and
what you're talking about can happen
very easily when other people are in the
group with my kids I mean because
they've been training jiu-jitsu so even
like against any normal kid
there's no factor yeah like I seem you
know my son will be wrestling around
with some kid it's no factor yeah
and it's you know it's kind of cool yeah
kind of cool yeah it's real cool yeah I
think little you know my kids aren't
like jujitsu like there's kids out there
that are sick competitive jujitsu all
the time yeah right yeah that that's not
what I'm talking about like just knowing
jujitsu a hundred percent correct yes
and but when I see kids doing jujitsu
especially like I'm not saying in
necessarily even in a tournament I'm
just saying in jujitsu in class they're
gonna at the beach or whatever when I
see like man I wish I could have done
just a locator you don't fun that would
be yeah man
yeah make up for it now that's right